the common view about the beginning of
the universe is that started with the
Big Bang and this is certainly the view
which has held for a long time but and
the question raised is what happened
before the Big Bang and the quiz your
answer to that question is well the
notion of before involves a notion of
time and there wasn't any time notion
before the universe was there so it's a
meaningless question and that's the sort
of response I would have given until
recently when I say recently this is in
the last decade and a half I've come to
the view that there was something before
the Big Bang my current view is that yes
there was a big bang it's not like the
old steady state theory well the
universe's was more or less the same a
new material was created created all the
time and then expanding expanded and new
material came that's not the view the
view is that the universe had this phase
called the Big Bang and then it's
expanded and it goes on expanding and
it's now indulging in this what's called
the exponential expansion which is
caused by what people call dark energy
now it's actually the case that in 1917
two years after unsign introduced his
general theory of relativity he put in a
term into the equations an extra little
piece which was called the cosmological
constant I introduced this in order to
have a universe which was static and he
knew that by putting this extra term in
the cosmological constant he could have
a model of the universe which stayed the
same all the time which is what he
wanted however he realized this was a
mistake
because the universe was observed to be
expanding and he when he clearly took
that on board he rejected his
cosmological constant however it turns
out that he was right all along in that
this term that he introduced has an
effect which causes what we
see now as an extra expansion that the
universe is doing it's sort of expansion
slow down and then it started to
increase in this exponential way which
is referred to well they call it
exponential expansion but it's referred
to as a result of maybe what they call
dark energy
now dark energy doesn't mean anything
it's a term I think it's a bad term
because the first part is called dark
and that would mean it would look dark
but it's invisible you look straight
through it it's not really dark it's not
even really energy because energy
according to Einstein is equivalent to
mass and mass attracts so if it's really
energy in the ordinary sense it would
pull universe back together but it
doesn't it pushes it away so it's a
strange kind of energy it's not really
but it is exactly what his cosmological
constant would do so the universe is
doing this exponential expansion now in
current cosmology there's also something
else which is introduced just after the
Big Bang looks just like this other
exponential expansion but it occurred
according to theory in the first where
it's hard to say is exactly but think of
a number with 32 digits a big number
take the inverse the reciprocal of that
very tiny number that fraction of a
second that ridiculously small fraction
of a second this thing called inflation
is supposed to have taken place that is
supposed to explain various things which
are hard to explain in cosmology in
other ways let's not go into that but
the current view is that the universe
didn't just start with a Big Bang there
was the Big Bang then there was this
inflation then it suddenly turned off
and then we had this more sedate
expansion and then we see this
exponential expansion again now now in
my view this original inflation didn't
happen but there is something very much
like it which is
the exponential expansion of what I'm
calling a previous Eon now what is an
eon this is a term I was glad to see
when I look up in the dictionary didn't
really designate any definite number of
years
it's an indefinite term so I was glad to
pick up on the term what an eon to me is
a Eowyn that is it is our eon started
with the Big Bang
no inflation the universe expanded and
then you have this exponential expansion
which goes on indefinitely that's one
year I claimed there was another Eon
before ours and it's exponential
expansion in this remote future was what
looks to us like the inflation that we
seem to see but it's not after the Big
Bang it's before it now that's a crazy
idea but this idea is crazy
and often we find that ideas seem crazy
turn out actually to be right so the
idea the hope here is that this crazy
idea does turn out to be right and what
is the crazy idea the idea is that each
yeon starts with its Big Bang very hot
very concentrated hugely hard I should
say expands out cools down the universe
then goes into this exponential phase
cools down cool down cool down gets a
very very cold what happens to the
universe well the most exciting thing
that's left over when the universe
starts expand away are these
supermassive black holes
our galaxy has in its center a black
hole which is about 4 million times the
mass of the Sun there's very good
evidence that right in the middle you
can see the stars going around it there
is a point you don't see it itself but
these stars are going around it and you
can plot these out and you know right in
the middle about 4 million times the
mass of the Sun is that little thing
well it's little by comparison but the
whole galaxy but it's big by comparison
with the solar
system it's not that small anyway that's
what we believe to be a black hole now
other galaxies have bigger ones as far
as we know all galaxies are pretty well
all galaxies having their sensors black
holes now as your weight and the
universe ages and the stars die and the
galaxies get very dire in the middle
will these be these black holes the
black holes swallow stars they will
swallow down most of the material in the
galaxy
and it's a very boring state of affairs
now it gets more and more boring though
because the black holes according to
Stephen Hawking and I believe him the
black holes are not entirely black he
says they have they radiate energy but
they radiate energy at a very very very
low rate it's as though the black hole
has a temperature and that temperature
is so cold but certainly for the big
black holes it's so cold that it's
colder than any temperature ever made on
the earth and the bigger the black hole
the colder they are now as the universe
expands the background radiation gets
colder and colder and colder and the
black holes become cold of it cold that
they are they've become the hottest
things around so they radiate away they
radiate away and eventually they
disappear so that's what happens how
long does that take for the biggest ones
well think in terms of a googol years
what's the Google the Google is one
followed by a hundred zeros it's a
made-up name and that's the sort of time
you've got to wait before these black
holes will disappear maybe longer than
that for the really big ones and when
they've gone what's there well that's
the very boring era it's extremely
boring and I didn't like the idea of
thinking that this is almost all of the
universe's lifetime would be such a
boring state of
Phares but then I began to think well
who's going to be bored by this universe
not us we would be long gone
but things that are around will be
photons and photons are very difficult
to bore partly because they probably
don't feel anything but that's not the
point the point is that photons don't
experience the passage of time that's
because they go with the speed of light
and because of the effects of relativity
that clock moving with this faster and
faster closer the speed of light slows
down if it reaches the speed of light it
doesn't register any time at all so as
far as that photon is concerned right
out to infinity is no time at all so
they'll never be anything well what
happens to this world and because of
ideas as I've been playing with a lot
when people were interested in me energy
in stars running around each other in
black holes and so on how do you measure
the energy radiated and the way to think
about this was to go all the way out to
infinity and you can do a little trick
which is a mathematical trick you can
squash infinity down maybe some people
will have seen these Asha pictures where
you see angels and devils interlocking
and you see as they get round to this
boundary which is a circle they get seen
to get smaller and smaller and smaller
right down to the edge as far as there's
angels and devils are concerned they're
all the same size as each other but
they're squashed down and away
which they squashed in all directions by
the same amount and then the boundary
represents their infinity but you can
see the boundary it's just there and if
you had a kind of geometry which didn't
know distances but the only knows shapes
and angles then infinity you can
represent in this finite way so I'm
taking the view that our universe is
very much like that the remote future is
just a boundary and that things which
have no mass have no way of telling
their size they have no way of measuring
time
that is the boundary they reach now this
is a crazy thought but the idea is that
that's what our universe is like and
when there's nothing around such as
photons which have no mass and therefore
they can't keep time their infinity is
that boundary then you can ask what's on
the other side of the boundary and what
I'm saying is what's on the other side
is the Big Bang of another Eon now you
might say well why doesn't the Big Bang
know where it is if you like the answer
there is similar but the opposite in a
sense when you get near the Big Bang the
temperature gets hotter and hotter and
the hotter the energies get bigger and
bigger and bigger and then the particles
which have their mass and which makes
them behave like clocks that mass
becomes irrelevant because the energy is
so much larger than the energy in their
mass then you can forget it that's just
to say they behave like photons they
behave like particles with no mass and
therefore they don't register its
passage of time they don't register
sizes so the Big Bang doesn't know
whether it's big or small anyway any
more than the remote future knows
whether it's big or small so it makes
sense to join them together now that's
the crazy thought but it makes
mathematical sense so it means that the
remote future of our expanding universe
becomes the Big Bang of the next yawn
and our Big Bang was the result of the
remote future of an eon prior to ours
and it seems like a crazy idea
but it does lots of things for us one of
the things it does for us is it creates
a universe which is very uniform which
is a great puzzle why the uniforms
universally being so uniform and it's
one of the reasons people introduced
inflation another thing it does is it
produces
Dark Matter now you see this is a one of
the current mysteries in the universe
most of the material in the universe
seems to be invisible to us we know that
from galactic rotation that there's more
mass in galaxies or almost all galaxies
then you see in stars and this mass has
been very puzzling you can tell from the
orbits of stars that there is more mass
around than you see in the actual stars
and it's been christened Dark Matter
that's quite different from dark energy
this is dark matter and that matter is a
kind of matter but it doesn't seem to
fit in with any theory of particle
physics it's something else now
according to the theory I'm talking
about when you cross over from the mote
remote future of the previous Eon that
the Big Bang of the next one you have to
the equations tell you you have to have
a new matter created a matter which
interacts with other things only through
gravity and that is what I believe is
the dark matter
now this dark matter eventually has to
decay away because you don't want it to
build up for me on to Eon so it got to
all gone by the time you get to the next
year and this decay rate is something
which has an effect on the next Eon and
you can tie all these things together
and it seems to make a theory which not
only makes sense once you've got the
idea of going from money on to the next
which is okay a crazy idea but it makes
mathematical sense and if it really is
true then you can explain where dark
matter comes from you can explain the
features of the Cosmic Microwave
Background this radiation which is
coming from all directions which you
previously needed inflation to explain
you don't need inflation you need the
previous year
and the things which we've been looking
at recently a Polish colleague of mine
Christophe
Meisner and South Korean colleague
Daniel Ann who's been doing a lot of a
computational analysis what we think
we've seen are points in the sky which
were calling Hawking points why are we
calling the Hawking points because the
black holes eventually evaporate away
and the energy in those black holes has
to go somewhere well it comes out mainly
in photons those photons concentrate the
energy in little points so that they
should be things that we you can see the
remnant of what used to be a
supermassive black hole coming through
on the other side to see these as little
points in the sky and we seem to see
these points which are hotter than the
background and they spread out because
of the it's because it's before it gets
to the place where you see the cosmic
microwave radiation according to this
scheme the black holes in the previous
Eon when they finally evaporate away by
Hawking evaporation all the energy that
used to be in the supermassive black
holes will come out in radiation mainly
photons others will be concentrated in
little points which the previously on
crosses over into hours they will look
like little points in the sky now they
won't be action to the points because
they will spread out you have to think
in terms of from the Big Bang time until
the radiation which causes the microwave
radiation that we see that's about
380,000 years
so in 380,000 years what used to be a
point has spread out to about eight
times the diameter of the moon so that's
the kind of size it would reach and what
apparently we see
our region's like this there would be
about from a little bit less than the
moon's
eight times the size of the moon to
maybe about three or four times the
diameter of the moon but splodge is in
the sky of that size which we seem to
see when I say we seem to see them these
are regions in the Cosmic Microwave
Background where the temperature is
slightly raised in the middle and then
as you go out from the center cool down
and the evidence for these points in the
sky is really quite significant and we
have an article in the on the archive
which we give the evidence for these
points but it's hard to explain on the
basis of current cosmology because the
current cosmology the temperature
variations which you see should be the
result of inflation this exponential
expansion which took place in the early
universe according to the theory and
according to sit in my scheme that the
inflation didn't happen and so if you
did have inflation you have to explain
how these are the points of raised
temperature nor regions of rage
temperature came about and it's very
hard to explain it on the inflation
review because the only way they could
come about on that scheme would be at
the very moment when inflation turns off
and it's a bit of a challenge anyway for
inflation because there's this problem
they call what they call the graceful
exit problem which is how does inflation
know to turn off all over the whole
universe in this sort of mild way and if
these points are recognized people isn't
really there they have to work they have
to make the inflationary scheme produce
these just at the graceful graceful exit
place and a bit difficult to see that
can be done anywhere my view is that the
inflation didn't take
but what we're really seeing is evidence
of the hawking of apparition of these
supermassive black holes which would
have been there in the eon prior to ours
and it will be very interesting to see
whether this really stands up or whether
there's some other explanation for these
points it's hard to see that the points
aren't there because the evidence from
them is statistically very strong did
you know that the institute of arson
ideas also has a podcast philosophy for
our times brings you the biggest ideas
from the leading thinkers around the
world every week search for philosophy
for our times and subscribe today on
your favorite podcast platform
SoundCloud or iTunes to make sure you
never miss an episode